exercises another topic is there a sweet
spot multiple studies say at the end of
a marathon if you draw blood on a person
presumably healthy a lot of them will
show the enzyme that comes from the
heart that leaks during heart attacks
will be present in the bloodstream of
healthy people after a marathon called
troponin but there's no reason to worry
people that you're shortening your
lifespan you may be calcifying your
heart arteries and it may be a bit of an
aging process I mean I think you'd
probably agree some of what you do is
putting your body under stress and the
ultimate course of it all but uh you
know I'm going on record it's great to
exercise but don't just cause you're a
high level athlete not know your
lipoprotein a not know your homocysteine
not know your C-reactive protein
inflammation and don't not spend 70
dollars and get a hard CT scan
recognizing you're going to need to dig
in and get a little research about what
do you do with it if it's abnormal